oh sorry I was confused by my producer
welcome once again to this week's
edition of the Android developer office
hours to my right our Joe Fernandez
hello and Alex elusive Lucas p excuse me
myers our producer on let's get right to
work here we have a question that's
currently in the lead how to make an
android unlocker app safer against
crackers i would love to have more
insight on this full details and then a
link to stack overflow right so we talk
like this one earlier yeah it's safe or
is the key thing not completely safe
against crackers of course one of the
things we were looking at yeah we've got
some audio problems we've got some audio
confidence okay wait one set bear with
us just right alright well we will oh
good Glen here I'm still working on it
haha still we're going to go close man
we're off air it says on the Google+ a
handout oh okay hmm culture
still working on it we move to a new
office today so anybody notice so of
course it's not quite okay guess we have
okay as test we're trying right now does
anybody hear us still working on it
Salkin yours no yes no maybe there's no
I own hairs hmm interesting you need to
pretty music for times like this we can
do it on jeopardy music or you know a
okay you can hear us again okay there's
no one else probably no one else can all
right now okay that hmm that's not so
good not good at all still a few bugs in
the system you left mount a few well is
it just an EOC since eight mountain it's
another office inside mountain view yep
there are now broadcasting from high
atop one android square mmmm ok unseen
mountain view I visited it's a google
office mm-hmm cool what do you think
critically yeah what did you think when
you visit our campus where it was very
asleep to see this giant android stuff
you know standing it out you know what I
came here for an interview they dropped
me off in front of the Android statue
garden I didn't really realize how
monstrous everything was right yeah with
the Android that CR twice as tall as I
am who's pretty neat well you know it is
everything so smooth so when you've got
that is so huge that's right we like
things bigger right it's not necessarily
better so can I finally a quick question
so myself please do sure why not a I
need to implement a facebook but I
implemented a facebook button you not to
with to draw some information using
facebook sdk and i did I use the
Facebook as he came in order to make my
batter but the problem is that I see the
button the button on my xml editor but
in when I learned the app on my galaxy
nexus I don't see the button it's still
taking taking personal calls no picture
no pictures no joy so you can see the
little layout editor but when you put it
on the phone it doesn't show up no it's
works fell 50 but no picture no and they
tied it on a different phone or so and
so when you say it works perfectly isn't
you can click the button you just can't
see it exactly it's an invisible button
which is pretty good but they don't
interesting debate not what you're going
for that's something I would find
challenging to do on purpose mmm but I
possibly there's some kind of resource
mismatch by the time it gets to your
phone sound like the layout editor can
find it but not the that's really weird
I don't see how you can let's this kind
of come on yeah I'm not really sure how
the special agents the layout editor can
see it right now a days with a child
instead of back on the chai Tuesday slc
option of the item you know to show it
as a picture not as a Raglan and it
showed the button but the picture was uh
you know it's cut it all the colors of
the picture so it's not really a
solution for it because I need the
picture
the size of the bedroom what objects are
using is it a button or as a amazing is
that custom button from the facebook sdk
cousin so is it not a nine patch or
anything something else no it's in I I
look for the code of this decay since
it's open sourced and it seems like a
normal battle but something they did
though makes it disappear once you aldea
maybe yeah so maybe there's a weird from
add to that is a PNG or something like
that all right it's a PNG gif png maybe
they've got some weird and coding in the
PNG that doesn't write that you're on
that phone doesn't know how to encode i
would say that unless somebody has a
really good idea um you should probably
post a question to stack overflow see if
anybody can answer it either from the
facebook facebook side of things or from
android yeah one of the thing i would
try for that is just just open up that
image and something else like gimp or
photoshop or something and resave it as
it doesn't other PNG maybe the format
maybe if it is a format problem that
might solve it so maybe this is like the
second bag that I already found in to
facebook is the king just okay well glad
you're giving them a workout over there
make sure your file bugs with them too
I'm sure they officiated the first one
which was pretty fun ease that if you
use a single signing you know to touch
the personally if you are one signing in
order to tow the person's information if
he already has the facebook app
installed on this device it will not
work oh oh that sounds like interesting
not such a good well tation there all
right we should probably move on alright
thanks for the question thank you think
are pretty sure has our stuff back on
track on let's go back to our are we
still on track here yes yeah okay we're
gonna go let's go back into the question
we were trying to work on
in which is how to make a nandroid
unlocker app say four events crackers
gentlemen all right still I'm doing this
one of you oh thank you very much cuz
it's because it's so easy and
straightforward so we were discussing
this before the show it's it's a
challenge safe or against crackers
versus being safe against crackers I
don't think you can actually get
anything completely safe against
somebody who's already determined I one
of the things i would recommend doing is
instead of having a separate unlocker
app use in-app billing instead
personally i think that's a better
solution for your app anyway because
that way your users don't have to salute
download a separate separate separate
APK in order to unlock your app so that
would be my first recommendation
implement in-app billing and then within
that you can find a lot of documentation
about how to make that that transaction
a little bit more secure so take a look
at the in-app billing again i think it'd
be a better solution for your users and
there's a quite a bit of documentation
about how to do more secure
implementations of an ambling there's
also a library that gets android it's
not one of ours it's a third-party
library it's like it's Android in-app
billing library i believe it is it you
can google that you should be able to
find that and that should probably help
you get that get that done a little bit
faster so moving on thank you next
question is what is the best way to give
access to a paid app to select people
without them bein I'm thinking something
along the lines of gift codes for
testers so they don't have to pay but
still get the updates from google play
all right um I'll take credit there's a
there's a few different solutions you
can try
I don't say that any one of them is like
the best like the one way to do this if
you're going with getting updates
through google play the best setup would
probably be to have the application as
free and the free on Google Play and
then unlock certain features via in-app
billing and then what you could do is
one way you can do it would be to sort
of bypass in that going if they enter a
coupon code in some play in some place
or have some sort of easter egg thing
worth a you know konami code we touch
the porridge of the screen various way
it unlocks or something like that and
for everyone else who doesn't have young
lock mechanism they could purchase
through in-app billing any other ideas
yeah i think some mechanism through
being at billing you might have a free
feature that you only allow for certain
people purchase yeah we're kind of
getting out on the edge of our own
personal knowledge space though but I
think your net billing and some some
variation on that it's probably your
best bet all right if foam if you don't
care about the updates happening through
google play then you can just distribute
distribute the app independently but if
you want to go through google play the
best option is definitely all right it
is always probably free app with in-app
billing okay thank you very much John
next question in ice cream sandwiches
are any way to control the camera and
flash from within a service like you
could in Gingerbread ICS seems to
require a surface preview right so
theoretically it should be possible to
do this I know that an ICS we changed
around a bunch of the API is actually to
make them a little bit more flexible and
ICS so it's possible that that's changed
what I would recommend here is actually
post a stack overflow bug for us and let
us know what's what what the problem is
and where you're running into an issue
it's completely possible than they we
may have introduced a bug is with the
ICS released so just in our comments
where do we want to have things posted
in the moderator add a comment to your
own comment here and give us a link to
this tank overflow bug but that's yeah
it sounds like it should be possible but
we need to take a look at the code and
see what's going on there thanks next
question have you ever thought of
including an RN will the SDK are there
any that you would recommend no and no
ah the weave the thing with mobile
programming's that we try to keep things
pretty lightweight and the lorentz added
a layer that doesn't really at least
none of the ones that I've seen from
personal experience really justify their
existence in the complexity they add on
the you know efficiency issues and stuff
an alternative to an hour to an RM would
be there's an open source project i want
to say what i say it was a MV SD or
something like that the con android MDS
d content provider basically a thing
that you sort of get your data model and
it will generate the the sequel commands
to generate the tables and generate a
content provider for you and you can go
in and sort of hand-tuned those but
that's and that should really in most
cases be all you need like I'm guessing
sort of from the context of the question
what it really is is I don't want to
write my own content provider from
scratch and everyone at this side of the
table sympathizes but no aureum isn't
really
ocean probably just getting a good
contact provider indicate the level is a
no comments okay um we'll move on then
the media store has a number of the ATK
one new one good all right what you so
I'm sorry I did skip over one they keep
on moving around um what about the state
of the android open accessory
development kit ATK seems nothing is
moved since it was introduced in 2011 so
I'll take that one I personally love the
ATK I've been using it in a bunch of
different projects I actually run my
lawn sprinklers off of it so it's I
don't think that it's a question of
whether or not it's moved there we
haven't changed the API or the ADK the
board itself however there's been a
whole bunch of other folks out there
who've created versions of the ADK the
arduino guys specifically have put out a
ATK mega that you can get directly from
from those guys and they're sold by a
bunch of resellers there's the yo-yo
bore that's available still which is
bill I oh I oh and a bunch of other
variants on it as well actually there's
a new version of the yo-yo board that
you can factor with bluetooth so you
don't even have to USB into it right so
hardware manufacturers have been making
all sorts of stuff right so we've kind
of the way I see what we've done is
we've kind of set the stage for people
doing more accessories and people have
take it off and run with it and gone
further than I think many of us thought
we were we would get with it so as far
as what future plans are that's a time
machine question so can't answer that
right now but lots of stuff are going on
great thank you very much now let's now
we can move on to media store the media
score has an insert image method for
inserting images into the appropriate
content provider why isn't there also an
insert video method of a similar fashion
what's the recommended way to insert a
video into the video content provider I
think we have two answers to this one is
the answer is no that's not possible
another answer is yes there is possible
so dueling aunt let's go I did not say
that was that there was no way of doing
it there was no insert video oh okay
we're back that uh I don't know why they
didn't write an explicit insert video
method i dunno I I just punched a couple
phrases into stack overflow it's my
favorite wave looking stuff up when it
comes to android developing android
development now i just typed into video
media store i think came up that
basically the answer is not to call
insert video but to call insert and then
as a parameter passed media stored on
video dot something dot content URI and
then a bunch of values I you can find it
pretty easily but it the key is to use
insert and state in the parameters or
you want to insert a video not to just
that there's no explicit insert video
great okay we want to take a question
from the hang up do we have any hang up
cliff face okay like just one moment
while we get some hang-up questions up
in front of us hi oh go ahead so I'm
working on an app and we're revamping
our tablet version but we're having some
problems with the fragment life cycles
we want to call back when like basically
like a non resume but the fragment on
resume method is tied to the activity
method and what we really need is
something so that when we display a
fragment on top of another one and then
dismiss that fragment that we get some
kind of callbacks so that we can refresh
that fragment the only thing that I can
really find is the exact change listener
but it doesn't tell you anything about
what happened all that says is the back
stack change so I was wondering if
there's a
a better way of getting a call back up
exactly what fragment became visible or
was hidden or whatever so are all of the
front so the one that's getting covered
up its attached the entire time that's
visible the entire time there's just
something else over it sorry it's not
estable there's another fragment
completely covering it all right but I
but I mean I understand it's not visible
to the user but I mean it has like
there's a is visible property so it's
still enjoys it sizzle okay do we have
callback for invisible or anything like
huh no I'm not actually I don't really
know how I would approach I don't think
there is a facility now that i think
about it for doing this just within
fragments i think what you need to do is
from within the activity have some
business logic that's tracking what
fragments are covering each other and as
they become visible like as you you know
remove the covering fragment when when
that fragment detaches have a call back
up to the para- it says okay refresh
whatever I was covering okay but that
just seems like I have to implement that
logic and every fragment I have and I'm
surprised there isn't built-in callbacks
let's see well you wouldn't really have
to implement a lot all you would really
have to implement is like on detach tell
the activity that I'm detaching then
you'd have to implement the logic for
for tracking that stuff like within the
put in the parent activity right or
create a base class for your fragments
that does that callback that does that
hey I'm going I'm going and rebel now so
that way you don't you know if they
could it wants a menu you extend all
your other fragments from that I made
about to re include it every time
without without actually looking at the
code in heaven you know full-scale
documentation in front of me and I can't
really say I can't really pull off the
top of my head with the appropriate
callback would be or
if one exists that you're writing that
it seems like it should but I can't say
for sure that it does plus it is to a
certain extent the pen activities
responsibility to manage the comings and
goings of fragments all right sort of
fallen did I purview anybody okay thank
you sure thank you very much for the
question um next question moving on do
we have anybody else in the Hangout that
wants to ask okay my producers saying no
or at least be shaking his head which I
assume that means he's saying no I'm not
trying I'm just trying to get in here we
got 20 um so the next question from the
moderator google TV development question
can we count on the four colored buttons
being on every Google TV remote if so is
there any standardization of what the
colors do on I've worked on google TV
and um as I believe those buttons are
not standard but the best thing that you
can do is um ask the google TV people
they do a hangout every wednesday just
before hours i think it's for one in
terms of two and if you ask that
question they'll be able to to tell you
as i remember on the only thing that is
needs to be standard on a google TV
remote is a number pad and a d-pad but i
would ask a little TV to be short okay
moving forward um is it possible to
change the theming of the overflow menu
potentially adding a glow or drop shadow
to it I don't remember first certain I
think it's possible to put custom views
in the overflow menu a producer shaking
his head I'm apparently making things up
today um cut that out I'm happy um so
with with that theory gone I believe the
answer then becomes no because the only
could think it would be do style the
individual views that you're putting the
overflow menu so unless unless you're
completely opening it lets you want to
reimplement your own overflowing right
don't probably unless you want to create
your own video and you but probably yeah
might be a lot more work than your than
you're really wanting I'm curious though
as to why I mean I if if somebody that
access question is in the Hangout right
now I'd like to know why they want to do
the custom theme for the overflow menu
on it may be that there's a different
way of achieving the functionality that
you want to achieve that's always my
question when somebody writes in can you
do X is what really are you trying to do
and is there a better way of doing it um
move on to the next question is there a
sync service for application data down
to a column value level that is sqlite
column value in a row that manages the
notification and transmission of changes
between devices in an efficient manner
all right so the short answer there's no
built-in one that does things on the
column of like that if like doing what I
said with the previous question if you
are in the Hangout I'd like to know what
the like the specifics of what you're
trying to accomplish especially when you
say an efficient manner that can mean
you know efficient as a very quick you
can be efficient for battery life
efficient for networking etc just to go
over a couple options one you can write
your own sync adapter to handle the up
and down stuff for you we also have a
backup API in a nandroid backup service
that handles the way we will host up to
one mega backup data and the way that
one works is that you you upload data
whatever you you basically whenever you
want you flag your data as dirty and
should be backed up and as the backup
service sees fit will sort of send it up
to the cloud and then you can either
manually trigger or when you're either
manually trigger
restore or when you're winning install
the app on a new device or reinstall the
app on the same device it will trigger
the data come down from the cloud we
also have the option of you can set up
your own custom app engine server side
and then are not even necessarily I
think you like whatever server-side
implementation you want you can send a
data up as you see fit and then use c2dm
to flag to send messages to your other
devices when there's data that is ready
to be synced but without knowing your
specific needs that I can't really say
what the best solution for you would be
and currently we don't have anything
that will sort of you know do magic
database version control and I on a per
column level without without any real
customizations on your part mm I would
add that um the question says
transmission of changes between devices
all right if you're if you're saying
directly between devices I certainly
don't know of anything on the the answer
that Alex is given is is a good one for
syncing to devices or two or more
devices with the cloud as an
intermediary which is actually it might
be what you're really trying to do that
certainly gives you the option of doing
multiple devices on between devices ah I
certainly can't think of anything off
hand and the first thing you would have
to do is decide how they're going to
communicate with each other um I think
we should move on let's go to the next
question which says when using an MHL
HDMI above the Galaxy Nexus can you
force the output display in portrait
mode currently it locks to landscape
with my droid charge and other devices
the TV would mirror the devices display
including orientation let's say so we
took a look at this one so let me give
you some background and this is nothing
necessarily a
question that's more about trying to
display something that's on your device
maybe you're asking this because you're
trying to do a demo and stuff like
whether it happened one printed on a big
screen TV so the MH MH l HDMI device is
basically a cable that plugs into your
phone and then it has a hdmi output
which then you can put into TV or some
other big display and then what their
this question is saying okay well if I
do that it always puts it in landscape
mode so I guess we were joking before
the before we came on air that well the
way to fix that is to just change your
orientation every television right and
then your problem solved but that's
probably not what you're going for I
think what we're looking at is a
limitation of that sort of output and
the HDMI that cable so I think you're
just looking at a hardware limitation
there and not something that we can we
can solve for you at this point and we
also like to welcome Trevor from
wherever the heck he is hi Trevor
everyone yeah i'm actually going from
living here it's 1030pm over here i
figured i'd hop on and see how you guys
doing and just say hello and any
questions if people come good always
glad for the backup thank you sir thank
you sir ah next question when reading
information from a USB MSC device using
the USB manager the bolt transfer
function on an in endpoint fails to read
data even with a proper cvw being sent
on an out endpoint first can you go over
the proper method for doing this yeah so
I've messed around a little bit with USB
manager but this is out beyond my Ken I
don't know Trevor do you have a
idea about this one unfortunately I
haven't done much with USB manage myself
be here so probably don't know any more
about this than you give all right so I
think we have to do a stack overflow
punt on this one so poster if you can
put a stack overflow question out for us
about what you're doing give us a little
bit more details we could try to tackle
that one great thank you uh this son do
we have any bunny doesn't look like we
have anybody waiting and the hang out
right now for questions so we'll move on
will abb on the device not a development
machine have an option to now allow
connection via USB and tcp/ip
simultaneously in the future it
currently doesn't as far as they know
meaning you can't wirelessly push da
apks two phones connected to it I have
you pronounce up yo yo board for he has
a younger board yeah yeah so I believe
this is I pretty sure I did this
actually a couple nights ago one when I
was working with a nadie que the way to
do this with a DB is first you have to
connect your development to that device
and then on the the connected
development machine type in he's a DVD
space tcp/ip and then you give it a port
number like 55 55 and then after that
point you can disconnect the USB thing
and connect it to whatever else you're
plugging in like your yo-yo board and
then I development machine type in a DBE
connects the IP address of your device
plus that port number 5555 for example
and you should be able to do logcat and
all the other kind of debug
functions that you normally do so I
believe that's in the developer
documentation if you want to go check
that out summer the developer tools bit
about how to connect through kynect TCP
connect a TB through tcp/ip but it is
doable i think i'm pretty sure i did
that reason why so ok let's mistaken i
think they're at least it used to be the
case of that required root because you
have to do a TV set up to go inside the
port number i'm not sure if that's
changed since then i know at least as
though i want to see one last time I
tried this was back on gingerbread
macdougall priori so oh yeah I think we
might wanna watch out for a lot of us do
use engineering devices which you have
at least limited Andrea access enabled
by default so unless anybody's been
running on easy gold and can click clock
terrifying when we're together again
might actually a part of this okay yeah
Trevor you're probably right i believe
yeah i may have been a doing a
development device at that point so
sorry you should be able to do it but
might not be able to do without rooting
your device okay well the information is
at least useful we'll see whether the it
helps out the person who asked the
question on next question is I like to
access specific small pixel count
arbitrary sub rectangles of a phones
frame buffer actually you know what
maisie write something for you on the
next question to make it worth noting
the question did mention that the user
is using a yo-yo right yes yep so the
latest yo-yo firmware actually does have
a really cool feature where you can plug
in a bluetooth dongle into the USB
forward rather than a USB cable and then
you come pair of the yo-yo over
bluetooth rather than over USB which
means that you can still remain
connected to your computer over USB and
use adb that way and then use bluetooth
to go and do the connection connect with
280 with the yoyo horn and
exactly for her open accessory data okay
cool cool yeah thank you for coming
thanks one on to come back to the
question that we were on I'd like to
access specific small pixel count
arbitrary sub rectangles of a phones
frame buffer asrat RGB pixel arrays at
high frame rates or even the uncorrupted
sensor data before RGB pixels have been
computed is this possible and is it in
Java or than the ndk I'm going to go out
alone and say it's probably not possible
unless you've got direct access to the
video the drivers for the camera on the
device and so that's going to be a
challenging implementation unless you've
got a very if you're targeting a very
specific device and you're trying to get
that specifically for that from that
device in the panel's so i would i would
venture to say probably not if you're
i'm sure if you're very determined and
are looking at a very very specific use
case you might be able to do this but i
think you're looking at a no or some
kind of other other solution going
through the API and clipping out the set
of pixel raise that you're trying to get
get to but getting the uncorrupted
sensor data I think you're gonna have a
really tough challenge there and might
have to write some of your own driver
code in order to do that and that's you
know if you're up for that great more
power to you but if you're looking for a
more general generic solution that
that's going to be tougher ok we have a
typed in question from the hang out some
apps try to use web view instead of
normal and drought layout items so it's
easier to support different platforms if
I do that and i have i have many views
in my layout where I gain or lose
performance oh my god says no idea eat
the entropy that you're gonna lose
performance there if she'll rendering is
a walk more heavy weight than native and
reviews and that's
to factor the fact you have this this
HTML document as we first then converted
into a dom and overall that tends to be
a very computationally expensive process
in order to what the entry delay out
system provides natively well also the
hardware acceleration doesn't always
play well with web views in fact
sometimes the performance is better in a
web view like without hardware
acceleration turned on so depending on
anyone with the rest of the app does you
can definitely lose out on some
performance by going the webview route
right so overall probably not going to
gain yeni it's probably going to be
faster to use a native layouts instead
of web views so it depends on what
you're trying to accomplish but if
performances the is the gold and I think
you're looking at doing native layouts
instead okay thank you very much uh next
question is I'm creating a bar graph I
want to move in scale existing items to
make space for the new item I animate in
the new item from the baseline
performance drops with greater than 50
items on the screen using view prop
annum what's the expected performance
and you have any suggestions for me oh
yeah the expected performance should be
about what 10 12 milliseconds on that
one no I won't talk I have no idea
actually with the perfect performances
on that why you're serious a second I
was you really going for that total
straight fish really yeah I don't know
idea performance depends entirely on
what you're doing and how you're doing
it and the device you're working on
device you're a bunch of other things as
well so really this is a very
fascinating question obviously you're
trying to solve a very specific problem
here again this let's do the stack
overflow punted please post that and
give us a link to that so we can try to
follow up on that one because we're not
going to be able to help you left the
top of us here if there are any relevant
code snippets that you can throw up
their daily not you know your entire
application but there's relevant you
know for loop repair
personal code that shows how you're
doing what you're doing we might be able
to offer some tips on it on a more
efficient way to do it we we can't with
the information provided say off the top
of our heads yeah how well that you like
what your frame rate should be or
anything like that that's right we
appreciate it you're working hard but we
need to take that one off line so next
yep my activity plays a video and use a
screen orientation equals landscape if I
hit the power button the activity is
restarted and video plays in the
background how can i prevent this I
tried config changes equals orientation
l keyboard hidden but no luck that's
fitted so I'm trying to curse with the
problem is here I think what you saying
is that that what what the question is
is that if a activity plays a video and
the power button is turned off um when
the power button is turned back on again
the activity restarts and the video is
playing in the background so this sounds
like there's a little bit of red herring
if the problem really is that the video
is playing in the background then I
think what you're here you need
something in your activity to say on
pause and stop your video playback
actually not it's not about your screen
orientation at this point it's more
about does your activity have only its
its methods implemented correctly so on
pause and on let's spawn resume on Zoom
yeah undestroyed maybe but I'm resume
and on pause are the two methods and you
looking at to make sure that that video
playback is stopped and in fact if you
look at the documentation for doing some
of the video recording and whatnot we
talk specifically about you know that
you should implement on pause and
museum specifically to stop that kind of
behavior right because you do not want
video playing in the background right
it's going to kill some of these battery
and your users are going to be very
unhappy with you either yeah I would add
that um in general you've got it you've
got to be aware of the activity
lifecycle and that the two most in
violence there's three there are three
not going to get into that I know too
well um there are three meth callback
methods that you definitely should look
at any time you code on activity on
create on pause and on resume on paws
will be called with anything leading to
the activity stopping including the
power button I'm almost certain that
that you won't be able to stop an
activity destroy it turn off the power
anything like that before on ponds being
called and similarly whenever an
activity is being started and it was
started before you'll go through on the
zoom there's where you have to make sure
that you clean up everything that's
going on because if you don't on that
your activity is still sitting there and
the minute that it gets on a signal to
start going again it's going to be
running and anything that you do stop
cleanup on prevent from jumping back in
again will rarely go on this way right
so thanks to the question redirected
next next yes I find the Eclipse logcat
view to be a bit inflexible to use for
example i can't select copy portions of
a log statement line i'm curious how
many of you preferred over using adb
logcat from a terminal this is really a
question to the Hangout um although our
experts could answer this one day one so
it seems to me I can copy and paste
portions of the log statement out of the
flawed CAD I you know for if you're if
you're trying to do a lot of text
processing and you're familiar with
command line utilities like you know
grep and whatnot then probably adb
logcat is maybe a better solution for
you so I think it depends on what you're
trying to accomplish again I think it's
possible i know i've done this with bug
reports and what nightclub flipping
things out of the Eclipse bottom log
report i know you have any thoughts on
this one I think uh I think depends what
if you're in the DDMS view I think you
can always want full lines at a time
okay in which kit and there's no like if
you it's almost a little bit misleading
because if you right click on it you
don't see a little neat lemon you pop up
that says copy or cut or whatever so I
mean you do have to use the keyboard
shortcuts in this control C but you can
still do it I actually prefer the
Eclipse feel with the embedded DDMS over
popping up an adb logcat in a terminal
window just because it's one less window
taking up space on my monitor yeah I
prefer to be working in Eclipse as much
as possible on especially when I'm you
know trying to develop something just
because I can hop back and forth between
what logcat said um and what's actually
in the code but then I i'm using eclipse
as an ide so i'm developing an eclipse
on obviously if you're not doing that
very much or if you're doing something
very complicated you might want to do
differently yeah okay I should also look
in excellent utility that Jeff Sharkey
on the Android team wrote which is
called color cat and that's a Python
filter for any luck at that will give it
a little bit of syntax coloring based on
what type blog messages being displayed
which makes a little bit more pleasant
to use than just generic adb logcat
that's good enough awesome what's it
called again color color cat okay you
search through his blog you can find a
link to it I think he might have we
needed to let color log
something like that but the original
person which is called polar cap right
and yeah it's been used to any log cabin
and thank identity so you told me to ask
the de color to it and right before max
for social easier to read but you can
still go and call me a start of it just
through a standard blog hat so super
this portion is a little bit of tweaking
bear tooth fairy username and then if
you hear that with another app called
air display you can actually go and take
a zoom or some other in their tablet set
it up as a secondary monitor and just
show your logs on that site display cool
and if you can't find the blog that
Trevor was talking about you can always
use your favorite search engine to find
them okay let's move on to the next
quest actually we have a hangout
question so go ahead hey what I want to
ask is they you know on GSM devices
you've got this option to connect to a
network based on the automatic
connection or to see all the networks
available then select one they want the
two of them is their way to get this
kind of information we using code and
getting the information of which
networks you can connect to an
information about those networks which
which carrier networks yeah there isn't
i'm asking is because we today a here we
add a new carrier started started
working again if they have two networks
one that is very nicely like about eight
megabits and the other one is like 0.05
so i'm trying and therefore doesn't know
which way to go so i would like to see
if there's a way by god to block it from
going to one and instead of to go to the
other is it was like a waiting possible
but i'm not i can't think about the top
of i-10 how you determine which network
and then pick one on the right I think
it's a system-level decision about what
network it's actually going to be
sitting on I sense it's a sense it's a
carrier david i'm working on a Wi-Fi
network
yeah but my guess is that it's not
possible but I can't say for sure to my
just it sounds like so do you think you
can have two carrier networks on the
single phone is that is that possible no
it's not do again is it's the same it's
the same carrier but since it doesn't
have a national coverage and I know that
will help set and gives it another
coverage and they both got the same name
so the fun doesn't know to which they
talk to go because it says it it's a
mate hmm i see so it's you're trying to
give it a preference because the phone
itself can't seem to figure out which
network it showed you up yeah which one
place to fess plan which one is really
slow I don't know um Trevor are you out
there oh sorry we lose me question your
time the question is on skinit the
developers getting this situation where
a single carrier is providing on to data
networks one of them has a much faster
speed than the other I think that's what
insane so the question is is there a way
to programmatically choose which one is
going to be used by the phone ok so
basically you need care to change it yen
settings then yes nothing no they've
been which they can use to select
because APN is the same define to the
network key you need to choose which
little to go to oh ok today I should
have entirely different where I oh
that's interesting um yeah I actually
don't think that to my knowledge with an
API available to do that lisa sparxxx or
political so I mean if persons always
possible this when I don't know about
that remain alleged I think you're going
to do that oh yeah I mean yeah sure
sorry about that uh we have a question
another question typed in from the
Hangout that says what is the preferred
way to share data between activities
that's a good one interesting um to a
certain extent depends on the type of
data if if its data that you sort of
want all activities to be
we're at all times i would say shared
preferences they're called shared
preferences for a reason like you you
set them up it's a series of key value
pairs that any of the activities in your
application can access if it's more
along the lines of data you want to send
as parameters then it would be intent
extras so we like within it you can
attach pieces of data to and in tanked
before you fire it you can add you know
strings are integers are just arbitrary
objects or whatever you want and it's
the same basic thing or it's a it's a
key value pair yeah I would say that
that that the answer is many times it is
is it depends on for instance I'm
assuming that these two activity between
the activities the activities are in the
same application because I if they're
not then there's clearly only a very
limited number of ways that you can do
it on if they are within the same
application then shared preferences is a
really good way um intense is another
good way um writing to shared storage
and you know using the common file name
it is another way it just depends on how
much data there is and what type of data
it is I mean if it if for instance it
was things like tabular data or images
or something like that I would be
tempted to write my own internal content
provider just because I'm real familiar
with with writing them on which would
make it really easy to keep them keep
the datas you know synchronize because
there's a lot of things that you can do
with transactions and stuff like that so
that you can ensure that the data is
always going to be the latest data
regardless of which activity is looking
at it so on I think we've summarized
shared preferences and tense content
providers etc it nailed it next right is
it possible to disable another
application for the intercepts all SMS
messages
I have an application that uses SMS but
other applications like go at some nice
blocked other blocks other applications
that handle the SMS message so he wants
to be able to stop go SMS from stopping
him his app from st. messages right it's
sort of one of those a radar versus
radar jammer questions or things just
keep incremental e one-upping each other
right i I'm trying to member the how SMS
works so there's two basic systems on
Android for these kind of broadcasts
there's the one where it goes to one
application at a time in each
application has the option of saying I'm
the only gets this right or ascending
sort of ethyl a while application for
SMS right or reddit the user has to pick
them from Houston Texas sent me an SMS
for Sierra to SMS receiver sorry SMS
letter score seeds as semester to person
named that so um the captures there's a
priority attribute that is set on the
broadcast receiver so in this case what
you want to do is set a higher priority
so this is actually a comment on the
post by simon mmm and he's absolutely
right you do need to set a higher
priority for Marie up for your broadcast
receiver to preempt the other one that
being said in so we get into an arms
race there so if you could have higher
priority you know if you accept our than
yours so at some point you just have to
uninstall the other out right so they
said priority 1 million you said
priority 1 million in one then you get
the
but then they recommend a million in
total and what part of it was the sort
of corollary to that is that if you sent
the message out for other applications
to process after you do then they don't
have to try to one-up you anymore
because they still get the data oh I'd
be curious if go SMS has an opt-in
feature for that or not I would also
recommend at least putting you know an
error message of some sort up that says
please adjust the these settings and
other SMS app so that this one can
actually see messages it's currently
being blocked by blah blah blah but the
pride the priority thing we'll fix it in
the short term way but it does become an
arms race so you might want to have some
backup solution place as well right okay
great next question I'm using batch
operations to access several content
providers in a high frequency I am
getting a warning warning reached back
sighs for compiled SQL statement cash
for database and then the insert process
quits how do I avoid that in Gingerbread
several different content providers in
high frequency yeah I I think the
question is asking I'm asked that
accessing several different content
providers I'm trying to do a bunch of
different inserts in rapid succession
and getting this error message arm so
he's spinning up inserts faster than
inserts can actually happen again I vase
I don't know what my problem is that I'm
not really sure what that error message
means um compiled SQL statement cash
seems interesting i'm not sure under
what circumstances an issued you can you
know that in batch operations you can
first of all um i can't remember
what the term is you can set batch
operations for a content provider to
yield on and that might be a way of
preventing this because you're not
trying to overload your system in
throwing all of these transactions and
you cannot expect that you can put
thousands of transactions into the
system and have them all go one right
after the other without yielding to
other systems or overload in the system
you points would be a good way of
dealing with this and also um there's
something else in apply batch that that
will make sure that you define that you
can define transactions and make sure
that on if something goes wrong that
they get backed out and retried um but
other than that I'm not really sure
there's a good way of avoiding this
other than figuring out your own
mechanism for not like overloading the
system's ability to update content
providers that whole process is
relatively slow in comparison to other
things so you need to be aware of that
and as you say use batch operations on
and you know use you points and only
send a certain number of transactions
over in a period of time on to make sure
that you're not overloading the system
Trevor do you have any ideas of what
would be a good way of sort of doing
self throttling for batch transactions
um it sounds like basically the one day
bike second I was trying to simplify
your blue object interacting you see
right there I'm not aware of any way to
go and for example modify these types of
feet our best will crash so I think it's
just a matter of trying to make sure
that i'm not sure i love to see when
he's actually running here yet i think
it's a piece of meteor simplifying the
SQL using or using some other equities
people like but aside from that my god
she never under this person so right i
would also have to say that it would be
very used
to see on the actual code that the
person submitting the question is using
to see if there's obvious ways of
increasing efficiency certainly you want
to be using things like insert rather
than compiling your own SQL statements
on Raw SQL statements are not the way to
insert things into a content provider if
at all if you can get away with in using
the insert method on that's what you
should be using because if there's a
variety of reasons for that so um let's
move on um what I have to use the ndk to
grab camera sensor pixels before the
JPEG compression has removed information
a raw RGB buffer would be ideal along
with exposure metadata i read that this
sort of access is available but it
raised by the phone in kemah yeah some
reminiscent of our the previous question
about trying to pull raw data off of the
camera sensor I not being familiar with
the ndk as much as I would like to be I
think the answer is you're probably not
if you're again if you're if you're like
writing low-level drivers and you've got
a very specific use case and you're
targeting very specific device maybe
that's possible but if you're looking
for a generic solution I think you're
it's going to be very challenging not
not completely undoable but maybe not
what you're what you want their side
look at other other ways to implement
what you're doing I think we've got
going but one more question and we'll go
to it is it always necessary to an it
loader from oncreate in a fragment what
if critical arguments for the loader are
dependent on the results of another
loader is it always necessarily doing it
loader in on cream for a fragment does
anybody know I hung my head think I
don't think it is I don't believe
I would be surprised I mean I definitely
done in in it low I'm usually doing it
loaders in oncreate just because um I
know that I'm going to be using them but
I don't think it's your requirement but
we'd have to look into that um certainly
once again on it would be nice to know
what you're trying to do so that we
could you know um give you a better
answer on how to best do it yeah so look
and follow up with a stack overflow
question as well loaders so it looks
like the question is about delaying
loaders and yeah I think the answer is
yes you can probably it's maybe
depending on how much data you're trying
to load in your fragment it might be a
good idea actually to do that yeah
because there's actually nothing in the
docs that says that this has to be done
inside of oncreate drug or when I can be
created our samples do you do with that
makes this you need to put it yeah but I
know where any restrictions actually
required I don't think there are any in
fact I um geez I think I've written um I
may have written something that doesn't
on an it loader later on just because it
loads one thing and when it gets the
results it it sets up another loader on
I will have to follow up with the stack
overflow question child can't be of more
help and I think that has done it for
today thank you very much for all of
your questions they were all really good
and we will see you next week